all right to this now a vigil will be
held today for Texas mother who was
murdered after she and her baby
disappeared investigators say 33 year
old Heidi Broussard was strangled she
and her three week old daughter
disappeared on December 12th the baby
was found alive at the same location
Broussard's body was discovered in the
disturbing twist Broussard's close
friend Megan fear mooskaa was charged
with two counts of kidnapping but no one
has been charged with the murder
Matea Villarreal is in Dallas Maria so
what do investigators go from here well
you know right now investigators are
saying more charges could be filed in
this case as they work to determine
exactly who killed Broussard and then
put her in the trunk of ierra Musco scar
authorities are also saying right now if
your Musco was telling people she was
pregnant at the same time Broussard was
in this elaborate plot reportedly to
eventually kidnap baby Margo for more
than a week heidi Broussard's friends
and family anxiously awaited word on why
the happy mother of two and her infant
child Margo had vanished the two were
last seen the morning of December 12th
where they lived in Austin Broussard had
just dropped her older child off at
elementary school and returned home
several hours later her fiance came home
to find Heidi and Margo missing with
Heidi's cars still outside the couple's
apartment her purse was inside the
vehicle a lead was generated that
created a location of interest in the
Houston area last week police and
federal agents zeroed in on this house
and silver sedan more than a hundred
miles away from boose ARDS home Megan oh
my god oh my god just before an arrest
was made Carissa Nolte a close friend of
Broussard was speaking on a true crime
podcast when new information started
rolling in about the investigation
that's Megan her best friend I met her
at church camp with me in a stunning
twist
police arrested Megan fair mooskaa who
reportedly was Brizard 'he's close
friend of more than 20 years she was
charged in connection with the
disappearance she was arraigned and
charged with kidnapping and tampering
with a corpse now the community is
trying to come to terms with
bruh swords tragic death I knew how much
she adored her family and so that has
been the toughest of it all
Vicki Medina worked at Cracker Barrel
with Broussard and says hide he made
everyone who walked into the restaurant
do you like family it's gonna be a very
big void on the behalf of all her
co-workers and the community because she
was there for so so long and I think
it'll be a while before everybody heals
and continues on a funeral for Heidi
Broussard will be held in Louisiana
right now her family is still working
out the details
as for babe Margo right now she is in
the custody of Texas Child Protective
Services
Jericka Maria thank you what a tragic
story I mean and then the other son you
know what happens to the other I think
eight or nine yeah yeah it's the idea of
which should be the happiest time for a
family now it has to deal with such
dread you heard Vicki Medina saying that
she made everyone feel welcome it's such
a horrible story right first for that
family
you